billy eilish is getting real about her
experience with porn what like it's so
weird during an appearance on siriusxm's
the howard stern show the bad guy singer
reveals that she started watching porn
when she was just 11 years old because
it made her feel like quote one of the
guys now at 19 billy is reflecting on
that time and says quote as a woman i
think porn is a disgrace i used to watch
a lot of porn to be honest i think it
really destroyed my brain and i feel
incredibly devastated that i was exposed
to so much porn the grammy winner
doesn't hold back also pointing out the
false image these adult videos create
quote i'm so angry that porn is so loved
and i'm so angry at myself for thinking
that it was okay the way that vaginas
look in porn is effing crazy no vaginas
look like that women's bodies don't look
like that we don't come like that billy
also shares how watching porn impacted
her intimate experiences she says quote
the first few times i had sex i was not
saying no to things that were not good
it was because i thought that's what i
was supposed to be attracted to as for
her views on dating now billy says it's
really hard to meet people and get this
last year she thought she'd be single
for the rest of her life but she's since
gotten over it the bad guy singer has
historically been very private about
personal matters i'm a speechless
speechless in her apple tv plus
documentary billy ilished the worlds a
little blurry fans got their first
glimpse into her dating life the most
unexpected and candid moments centered
on her rollercoaster relationship with
brandon adams also known as q or seven
amp the pair shared i love use and
talked over the phone throughout the
film but ultimately split as billy
struggled with trying to quote fix him
and it was important to show all aspects
of what she experienced as a young woman
coming of age in this moment so as a
result q is a big part of that most
recently eilish was linked to actor
michael taylor vorse in april they were
spotted cozying up in santa barbara
we're all just doing our thing you know
what i'm saying when it comes to her
career billy couldn't be doing better i
am so excited to be here my name is
billy ilish the singer hosted saturday
night live for the first time recently
and got high praise even while breaking
character a time or two
[Applause]
and breakfast and breakfast
and breakfast means morning here at
business garden and and suites and hotel
room in et has spoken to billy many
times over the years including the 2021
met gala when she was co-chair at the
event and couldn't help but gush about
the opportunity it's
like the most insane honor you would not
believe i feel like
i'm in a dream
i feel like i'm like tripping
you said that you were feeling a lot of
nerves
yeah like good ones though like nothing
literally not one bad i just am like
this is the most exciting thing i've
ever done